Jeff welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thanks Dave
glad to be here so what is your net
worth sir 2.8 million all right very
cool what's that invest it in most of us
in mutual funds and I paid off house all
right what's the house worth and
probably 350 or so okay very cool and
how much of that did you inherit a zero
okay and how old are you I'm 57 and my
wife is 53 okay very cool and throughout
your working life time what was your
average income probably about a hundred
and twenty-five K my very first year was
13,000 and moved up from there to about
240 now what kind of careers are you in
I'm in the services computer business
and started as a service technician and
moved up to various different management
levels what's your degree in I actually
have an associate degree in electronics
but not a bachelor or anything else
other than that so to your point earlier
you know you don't have to be rocket
science to be a millionaire yeah and
what was your net worth on the associate
your net worth your GPA on the
associate's degree it was a round three
okay about what I was saying then yeah
go and how many brand new cars have you
bought probably four or five in the last
you know maybe fifteen years I bought
one when I was in my early 20s and found
out that wasn't a really good idea
especially when I didn't have the money
but now is that we've come into the
money I usually buy a new car and you
know rag it down and then you know go
buy a new car with cash yeah yeah well
you got the money well you know as you
waited do you were a millionaire to do
that yes yeah so what's the most
expensive pair of jeans you ever bought
probably about 30 bucks whatever the
hallmark price is today got it how much
debt have you used to build the wealth
the only thing that we've actually done
well for the wealth really none I mean a
house mortgage was it was the only thing
we had for the well Jeff thank you your
great American success story I
appreciate you sharing your life and
your numbers with us this is a great
service you're doing thank you very much
it's a millionaire theme our on the Dave
Ramsey show